Dr. Zakir, are there to your mind any
important sunnas of the prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam that people
avoid because they feel it will nullify
their fast?
>> Yes, there are a few sunnas of the
prophet which many Muslims avoid
thinking it will break their fast or it
is makum. And the most important sunnah
of the prophet which people avoid during
Ramadan is using the using the tooth
stick. Many Muslims feel that if they
use this it is makru. The main reason is
there's a hadith of sallallahu alaihi
wasallam a hadith which is mentioned in
say bkari volume number three book of
fasting hadith number 19 and four where
the beloved prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said I swear by Allah in whose
hand is the soul of Muhammad peace be
upon him that the breath of the person
who fasts
is more sweeter to Allah than the scent
of musk. Now based on this hadith many
Muslims think that if they use the sawak
the breath the bad breath or the foul
breath of the person who fast will not
be there and it will not please Allah.
That's the reason they avoid using
savak. Now these people they fail to
realize that when we use the stick civak
it does not remove the breath the foul
breath or the breath which people
normally don't like of the person who
fast. The civak mainly brushes the gums
it cleans the teeth. It helps in keeping
the teeth healthy but in no way does it
reduce the breath especially of the
person who fast. And furthermore,
there's a sunnah of the prophet where
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam he
said it's mentioned in say bkari volume
number two
had number 887
our beloved prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said that
if it wouldn't have been too hard for my
ummah I would have made it compulsory
for them to use the civak the tooth
stick before every prayer or to use the
tooth while doing voodoo like how voodoo
is a requirement before salah the
prophet if it wouldn't have been too
difficult for he would have made it
compulsory to use the tik and here he
did not mention any exceptions other
would have said I would have made it
compulsory for my um except during
fasting this important sunnah surely if
this would have been makru while fasting
would have nullified the fast surely he
would have mentioned it so this proves
that this is important sunnah which
Muslims should continue doing even
during the month of Ramadan even while
fasting it will not nullify their fast
it's not makru in fact it is mustab it's
encouraged and the other important
sunnah which people neglect or avoid
mainly fearing that it will spoil their
fast or nullify their fast is putting
water in the nostrils sniffing the water
normally especially during voodoo so
many of the Muslims even when they do
voodoo they just get the water close to
their nose and touch the tip of the nose
to the water. That's it. They don't put
the water into the nostrils and they
clean their nose. They don't sniff it.
Which is a requirement for voodoo
thinking that if they sniff it may break
the fast. Water entering through the
nose into your throat will nullify the
fast but the chances are very
negligible. What our beloved prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam said it's
mentioned in a say had abu number two
hadith number 2360 a beloved prophet
said that when you do voodoo sniff the
water excessively except in fasting. So
normally when we do hoodoo we sniff the
water excessively except in fasting
because in fasting if we sniff
excessively there are chances though
very negligible for it to enter the
throat and nullifying your fast but
normally when we put water in the
nostrils there are no chances of it
going in the throat. The only care that
we have to take while fasting is don't
sniff excessively but we have to put the
water in the nostrils and clean the
nostrils which is important sunnah which
many of the Muslims neglect and they
avoid it especially during voodoo and
here since the prophet clearly mentioned
except fasting
during the sak he said I would have made
it compulsory had it not been difficult
for my um there because he doesn't say
fasting it means that can be used while
fasting and sniffing should not be done
excessively but normally water should be
put in the nostrils while doing voodoo.
So these two important sunnas which
people out of ignorance they avoid
during fasting.